hundreds of containers of food and other
commodities are stuck at lebanon's ports
there are no workers to unload them it's
been three weeks since employees and
public institutions went on strike to
demand better pay as the financial
crisis enters its fourth year
this strike has really paralyzed our
work it
affected all our transactions in the
port of the beirut
in the airport
a lot of cargo and containers are
waiting for the employees we need every
bit of income we need every bit of
import
and without the employees of the
government it will stagnate the economy
the state is nearly bankrupt and it's
losing an estimated four hundred
thousand dollars a day because of the
strike
it's also creating problems for citizens
who are unable to do necessary paperwork
but state employees like much of the
population say their salaries are now
worthless after the local currency the
lira crashed
we can no longer reach our place of work
because of high transportation costs we
can't afford the basic necessities our
salaries are worth 50 to 60 dollars the
government has not dealt with this issue
in a serious manner even though more
than a million people are affected
there is no official figure but it's
believed the lebanese state employs
nearly 350 000 people but international
financial institutions say it is
overstaffed corrupt and used by the
political class as a tool to win loyalty
it's very large for the size of the
country it constitutes 25 of the
workforce but any dismissal will lead to
a social catastrophe unemployment is
about 38
and there are no jobs end of service
compensation is also worthless because
of the currency devaluation
for many years public wages and benefits
constituted more than 35 percent of
government spending many warn against a
pay rise without a comprehensive
recovery plan
reforming state institutions and
fighting corruption are the only ways to
unlock foreign support and trigger
growth but politicians are refusing to
do that instead they are locked in a new
struggle about power in the next cabinet
employees say they won't return to work
until their demands are met but the
government has little options it doesn't
have enough sources of revenue it can't
impose more taxes on an impoverished
population and it can't print more money
without causing further inflation
senator al-jazeera beirut